- I find women's underwear
to be pretty, uh...
uncomfortable.
So, I want to see what the guys got.
- I feel like this is
really going to open me up
to what men feel like.
- I can't imagine it's comfortable.
- I think I could do a good job
of imagining having a penis.
BuzzFeed presents,
Women Try Men's Underwear
For The First Time.
Briefs
- [Woman] I feel like this is important
in that, I'm going to understand
the other sex better now.
- Yo! This is weird!
- They're so high. I don't
know why they're so...
And then there's this pocket.
I feel like, you like take
it. Actually I don't know.
- Do you have to use as a snake?
Do you snake it around the first layer?
- Is it for peeing?
- Do you use this pee hole?
Or, do you just take the whole thing off?
- Do guys not pull their underwear down
when they pee?
I've never seen a boy pee.
Boxer Briefs
It is a flap.Where does the dick go?
- Yes. This one is a pull 'em out.
Just whip 'em out on people.
That's what this one's for!
- Except for like the
tennis ball-like pattern
that's right here, which I
think is kind of strange.
- So, just like confused because it's like
what shape is this for?
- Like your dick is a baseball.
Boxers
- [Lady] I love these.
- [Voiceover] You love these?
- I love these.
I feel like I'm in a
cute, Aerie ad.
- I think they're adorable, first of all.
- But, then you've got
to put pants over these?
- Yeah. There's just so much happening.
- Feels like too many
layers. Too many pants.
- Putting pants over pants.
So what the (beep) is this?
What we've learned.
You mean, dudes are afraid of a situation
where they can't get their
dick out fast enough?
And they're like, "Quick!
Pull out this way,
"pull it out this way! Fire in the hole!"
- The difference between
like boxers, and briefs,
and boxer briefs is like minuscule.
If you're not wearing a thong,
I don't want to hear about it.
- You ever see that guys
who reorganizing so much.
You know. There's a lot happening that
we don't necessarily know about.
If they're wearing boxers,
just give them a pass.
- So like guys, really!
There's just so much
fabric here. It's just confusing.
- Well, It's like on an airplane,
like, "Your exits are here, here, here."
Your dick can come out in any of the ways.
BuzzFeed presents